es muy común ver en los libros de
cálculo algunos problemas parecidos al
siguiente digamos este demostrar
demostrar que el límite cuando x se
acerca a 1 déjenme pensar una función
interesante digamos
algo interesante cuando x se acerca a 1
sería 3 x x x menos 1 / x menos 1 y aquí
a lo mejor me dirás oye por qué pusiste
x menos son en el numerador y en el
denominador bueno porque yo no puedo
dividir por cero verdad entonces
realmente no está definida esta función
en uno verdad en todos los demás valores
sí así que esta es la línea 3x y tiene
un hoyo cuando x es igual a 1 por eso lo
hice así quiero calcular el límite
cuando x tiende a 1 de esto y los libros
irán hoy a ver en demuéstrame que el
límite de esta función cuando x se
aproxima a 1 es estrés demuéstralo y
básicamente lo que tenemos que usar es
la definición de épsilon si deltas del
límite así que para probar esto
esencialmente tenemos que demostrar lo
que significa y lo que significa es lo
que vimos en el vídeo anterior es decir
demostrar
da da da da una épsilon positiva y
recuerda que épsilon era la distancia
que deseamos acercar fx al límite
entonces dada esta épsilon positiva
quiero demostrar que puedo darte una 1
quiero demostrar que existe que puedo
dar una delta positiva donde
en la distancia donde si la distancia de
de x a 1 es primeramente menor que delta
y mayor que 0 para que no sea uno verdad
no no quedarnos justo en el límite ajá
porque en el límite no está definido
verdad entonces nuestra distancia tiene
que ser mayor que 0 para no tomarnos x
igual a 1 entonces tengo que demostrar
que si tú me das una épsilon yo puedo
encontrar una delta a una delta que a lo
mejor está dependiendo de de la eps y
long que puede ser una función de
épsilon entonces si la distancia ésta es
menor que delta podemos garantizar que
la distancia de esta función 3 x 3 x x x
menos 1 entre x menos 1
la distancia entre esta función y el
punto límite que es 3
-3 esto va a ser menor que épsilon
perfecto entonces muchos libros de
cálculo te lo van a poner así límite de
fx cuando x tiende a a es igual a l así
es como se escribe y lo que significa es
que tenemos que demostrar todo esto que
escribimos aquí verdad
entonces de todos modos cuando alguien
quiere decir que lo demostramos
básicamente quiere que dada la épsilon
encontremos la delta la delta de que yo
voy a decir quién es la delta yo tengo
que encontrar la delta tal que se
satisfacen estas desigualdades siempre
que x viste de uno menos que delta y
entonces la función de instala del punto
límite que es tres menos que épsilon y
cómo lo hacemos bueno solo diré bueno
después de un montón de pruebas ya he
visto que no hay una forma sistemática
de hacer esto
es algo mejor un reto interesante a
ciertos niveles pero bueno este problema
que les he puesto en cierta medida es
bastante fácil cuando te piden hacerlo
pero generalmente involucran partir
inicialmente del lado derecho manipular
algebraica mente hasta que obtengamos
alguna expresión que involucre el del
lado izquierdo entonces tendremos algo
menor que delta y entonces podremos
decir que delta es una función de
épsilon por ejemplo que fuera 3 épsilon
y entonces delta tendría que ser épsilon
sobre 3 verdad entonces y así habremos
demostrado el teorema tenemos que ir
haciendo manipulaciones algebraicas
comenzando de a dónde queremos llegar
para averiguar cuál es la delta que
esencialmente me funciona y que puede
ser una función de épsilon entonces por
ejemplo este voy a darle realmente la
vuelta al problema verdad este podemos
no sea lo mejor tomar una delta igual a
épsilon entre 10 oa lo mejor la raíz
cuadrada de épsilon en fin vamos a
iniciar cancelando las x menos 1 y
podemos hacerlo porque x es distinta de
una verdad supusimos que no era 1 porque
si x es igual a 1 la función no está
definida y eso está bien porque nos
interesan los intervalos en donde la
distancia sea mayor que 0 es decir que
no sea 1 así que hasta ahorita todo va
bien esto se simplifica a lo siguiente
de aquí pasamos a que el valor absoluto
de 3x menos 3 debe ser menor que épsilon
muy bien entonces factor izamos un 3 y
tenemos el valor absoluto de 3 por x
menos 1 debe ser menor que épsilon y ya
veremos que aquí tenemos nuestra x menos
1 si pasamos este 3 del otro lado ya
podríamos haber resuelto el problema
esencialmente así que el valor absoluto
de 3 por x 1 es el valor absoluto de 3
por el valor absoluto de x1 verdad
porque si yo quiero que lo de arriba sea
positivo pues lo de abajo es una
multiplicación de dos positivos que
están dados por el valor absoluto si no
me crees sustituye varios numeritos y
vas a ver que esto es cierto entonces
a lo mejor un profesor ahora en adelante
te va a decir que esto de acá arriba es
cierto si y sólo si esto de abajo y que
lo pintan con dos flechas y bueno lo
resumen con ese y digamos como si no
entonces que quiere decir que lo de
abajo es cierto implica que lo de arriba
es cierto y si lo de arriba es cierto
implica que lo de abajo es cierto
entonces esta expresión es cierta si
sólo si la de abajo es cierta y también
pasa si sólo si es cierta la de hasta
abajo verdad entonces el valor absoluto
de 3 es 3 ok y entonces dividimos ambos
lados por 3 es decir le podemos quitar
el valor absoluto porque el valor
absoluto de 3 es el mismo que es 3 y que
tenemos que el valor absoluto de x menos
1 es menor que si lo de entre 3 que
hemos hecho hasta ahora hasta ahora
hemos demostrado que el valor absoluto
déjenme déjenme
escribir esto en otro color sólo hemos
demostrado que el valor absoluto de 3x
por x 1 entre x
1 - 3 el valor absoluto de eso es menor
que si long sí y sólo sí sí solo si
ocurre que el valor absoluto de x menos
1 es menor que epsilon entre 3 verdad
así que esto pasa siempre y cuando yo
tenga que la distancia de x a 1 sea
menor que épsilon entre 3 correcto
entonces podemos utilizar a esta eps y
long entre 3 como nuestra delta okay
recordemos que el punto de todo esto era
que si me daban una épsilon que era la
distancia del cual yo no quiero pasarme
de mi punto límite quería que la función
estuviera cerca del punto límite tanto
como la épsilon de verdad y esta es esta
distancia aquí está
fx esta es
y esto es lo que aproximamos verdad y
digo que esto pasa así solo si la
distancia de x a 1 es menor o bueno la
distancia o el valor absoluto
si esto se aproxima menor que épsilon
entre 3 así quedará cualquier número
épsilon si por ejemplo tú me dices oye
yo quiero que no pase de 1 que esta
distancia no sea mayor que 1 entonces yo
te digo bueno entonces x1 debe
a distar perdón debe estar x de 1 menor
que un tercio en otras palabras 3x x x 1
/ x menos 13
si yo tomo el valor absoluto de eso y
quiero que sea menor que 1
por supuesto x no es 1 entonces no
debemos estar más lejos de uno de un
tercio de un valor de un tercio verdad
que es épsilon entre tres en este caso
de épsilon vale uno entonces me diste
una épsilon igual a uno ahora lo que
puedo decir es que
esto pasa si sólo si la distancia de x a
1 es menor que 1 entre 3 que es un
tercio y realmente tiene mucho sentido
si vemos la gráfica de esta ecuación
déjenme ver digamos aquí está el eje x
acá está el eje i
esto es similar a la ecuación de 3x
excepto que tiene un orificio en x igual
a 1 déjenme dibujar la gráfica
digamos con esta pendiente de una
pendiente 3 bastante pronunciada o algo
parecido verdad entonces cuando estamos
en x igual a 1
perfecto aquí hay un agujero aquí hay un
agujero y aquí vale 3 muy bien entonces
todo lo que estamos diciendo estamos
demostrando de hecho que si queremos
estar cerca de nuestro punto límite en
no más de 1 es decir si tomamos una
distancia de épsilon igual a 1 digamos
así de grande esto es esto es un número
bastante grande así que si queremos
estar alrededor del punto límite en no
más de 1 baja entonces lo que estamos
diciendo es que tampoco debemos pasarnos
de 1 más de un tercio
y que lo podemos visualizar de esta
forma exactamente aquí hay un tercio y
aquí hay otro tercio o podríamos haber
dicho en términos más generales y esto
es épsilon acá será épsilon entre 3 y en
la razón de esto pues es la prueba de
que no importa que el siglo me des yo
siempre puedo dar una delta tal que de
hecho es el filón entre 3 y como la
cualquier número lo puedo dividir entre
3 esta delta está bien definida y hemos
comprobado a través de la definición de
épsilon si deltas que el límite de esta
función cuando x tiende a 1 es igual a 3